over many months it was an impending
ruling that had rattled a nation
division anger emotion
and there is now a group of people for
whom this judgment will have the most
profound most painful impact
for them to be making these decisions
right now
is just simply unbelievable to me
trish mitchell is a survivor of rape
when i discovered i was pregnant i was
overcome with fear i didn't know if i
could provide the love the nurturing
care and support
to a child
that
was a result of rape i wasn't sure i was
capable of that at that age i was only
22 when this took place and i didn't
come at that decision lightly it was a
very difficult decision to make but in
the end it was the best that was for me
and my family
abortion was her choice one that she
could legally make her constitutional
right
now taken away
and if you thought that there will be
exemptions for rape for incest we'll
think again because in 11 of the 50
states across this land it doesn't
matter if your pregnancy was the
consequence of a sexual assault state
laws are set to require that you give
birth to that child
i considered taking my own life at that
time i considered not dealing with it at
all simply because i didn't have the
tools to deal with it i wish they
understood the trauma that comes along
with being sexually assaulted i wish
they understood how
vulnerable you feel and how you feel
like you have no decision no choice in
any of the situation
three million women in america are known
to have experienced rape related
pregnancy in their lifetime the true
figure will of course be higher many
choose not to report such awful
experiences but over many months
following this debate we found the
ideology which drives the anti-abortion
movement is deep and if the woman has
been raped or a victim of incest
we should kill the rapist not the baby
the baby didn't have any part in it
[Music]
the fear now is that this will
precipitate a public health crisis with
the most vulnerable now the most in need
i think about how many women we might
have to step over on a bathroom floor
because they've made the decision to try
and terminate their pregnancies
themselves or how many women don't have
the means to travel to another state
where abortion laws are different
in order to have the proper care and the
proper treatment
for
terminating a pregnancy
it's pretty scary
right or wrong this judgment represents
a fundamental shift for women and for
choice across this land part of
america's social fabric has just been
unwoven
mark stone sky news in kansas city